observer pendant deux ans vous me donnez
là bien mauvais exemple mais je ne veux
pas m'engager davantage
moi je je vous appelle il ne fait aucune
observation particulière sur votre façon
de vous exprimer vous en avez le droit
moi je continue vous appeler monsieur le
premier ministre puisque c'est comme
cela que je vous ai appelé pendant deux
ans et que vous l'être et bien en tant
que premier ministre j'ai constaté que
vous aviez et c'est bien juste de le
dire le train et la qualité vous n'êtes
pas celle de l'impartialité et du sens
de la justice dans la conduite de l'état
permettez moi juste de vous dire que ce
soir
je ne suis pas le premier ministre dit
vous n'êtes pas le président de la
république nous sommes deux candidats à
égalité
et qu'ils se soumettent au jugement des
français
seuls qui comptent vous me permettrez
donc de vous appeler monsieur mitterrand
vous avez tout à fait raison monsieur le
premier ministre